I know how to break the news to Bob and
the kids this is the diary entry Debra
Douglas wrote on the day she was
diagnosed with breast cancer your hugs
and stay strong for each other that was
the biggest shock he told me that the
lump would have to come out she had
chemotherapy and a mastectomy but years
later was recalled and told neither had
been necessary and the full mastectomy
she thought her surgeon Ian Patterson
had carried out was only partial now
down the line I realized that none of
this was necessary I should have had a
lumpectomy not only did he leave me
scarred physically and mentally but he's
left me at risk of a reoccurrence of
breast cancer if I need you the mistakes
me should have removed all the breast
tissue Ian Patterson was jailed for 20
years in 2017 for carrying out
unnecessary and unsafe operations his
unregulated partial mastectomies meant
cancer returned in many patients some
have since died an independent report
has found hundreds of his patients were
not only harmed by him but failed by a
culture within hospitals of avoidance
and denial it's the story of a
healthcare system which proved itself
dysfunctional at almost every level when
it came to keeping patients safe the
report found evidence that complaints
were ignored the behavior of some of
those who worked closely with Patterson
was found to be so bad
five have now been referred to the
General Medical Council or Nursing and
Midwifery Council and one matter sent to
the police my report sets out what can
only be described as willful blindness
in relation to Patterson's behavior and
aberrant clinical practice colleagues
avoided or worked around him some could
have known others should have known and
a few must have known concerns were
raised by in Patterson's colleagues as
early as 2003 had they been acted on by
the private and NHS hospitals where he
worked here in the West Midlands
he could have been suspended then
instead he was allowed to continue
working for a further eight years with
devastating consequences leslie cuss
pert had major surgery after she was
told by Ian Patterson that she had
breast cancer
in fact she didn't have cancer at all I
feel really angry about that because if
people had been listened to and he would
have been suspended in 2003 and my
operation being in 2006 means that I
wouldn't have had to have gone through
any of this at all the report makes 15
recommendations to improve safety
including more information about
consultants being made public better
communication between consultants GPS
and patients and more effective
complaints procedures in NHS and private
hospitals we can't guarantee but this
will never happen again what we can say
what I can say today is that I the
department we will do our very best to
make sure it never happens again spire
health care has apologised and accepted
opportunities to challenge
Ian Patterson's behavior were missed
Patterson's patients fear unless
improvements are made there's a risk
more people could suffer like they have